bonjour comment allez vous moi ça va
extrêmement bien les amis aujourd'hui je
souhaite prendre ma revanche sur un jeu
qui m'a profondément fait du mal mais
aujourd'hui j'ai la chance d'avoir un
atout extraordinaire un génie a fait son
apparition il m'a dit lui car je vais te
donner un pouvoir et que tu te crées à
la porte ici quelqu'un viendra pour
t'aider et là je me suis réveillé nacho
avait poussé sur le tapis donc j'étais
très content au cannet nouveau sur ce
maudit jeu avec ce [ __ ] chaudron et ce
marteau vous connaissez très bien
aujourd'hui parce que j'en suis au tout
début du jeu j'ai fait que tomber du
coup je me retrouve au début de jeu
c'est incroyable ce qui se passe quoi
faire c'est que je vais essayer tout
seul est arrivé si je rage trop j'irai
toque à la porte quelqu'un viendra
m'aider parce que mec je n'en peux plus
en plus j'ai perdu la main mec ça me
fait déjà les couilles hockey [ __ ] de
merde et un croate en ont mais mc j'ai
perdu la part des québécois je m'en bats
les couilles mec assis toi la jeune
touriste est ce que tu vois ce jeu non
non mais j'ai déjà mais le premier
niveau est pas allée très loin excuse
moi mais qu regarde pas les genoux
montré non vrai je sais pas avec donc
c'est bien si j'ai mal joué c'est bien
un mec dans un pot qui est tout nu c'est
ça c'est donc ça c'est bon c'est comme
un conte soirée ok c'est bien c'est bien
tu ça m'énerve quand il fait ça ça
m'énerve quand il fait ça ça va et toi
même tu as compris dans le cerveau
caisse et mais attention maintenant
l'astute incombera aux attentions
attention
vas-y vas-y j'appelle à youtube y en aa
c'est terminé c'est ce que je cherche
c'est ce que les gars je vais rester à
toute la vidéo une foutent de la gueule
de tout les gens qui vont passer il faut
vraiment que tu réussisses a passé ces
[ __ ] niveau ça fait 15 ans que je
fais da de sa d'accueil en vrai je suis
entraîné un peu j'ai compris que la
technique c'était sa bombe asie alors
essaie juste de passer à temps ouais
c'est une victoire
ouais merci mais qu'est ce qu'un homme
comme sa voix voilà
il est pas hyper calme mais la tension
comment tu balances sur le rocher revel
droite à droite
voilà là je suis baiser en fait c'est la
sérénité et c'est tout c'est toute la
méditation fait qui font six auteurs qui
permet je sais que c'est inique et
sérénité méditation et la [ __ ] sofiane
s'te plaît
après la mecque fort parce que là moi je
vous invite à lui dit non c'est pas un
tueur qui rentrent attendait déjà enfin
mes grands s'étaient déjà enfuis toi la
[ __ ] la baisse la tête table sur la
nuque on est parti attend juste un truc
mieux vaut avoir le plus nul dès le
début oui c'est vrai le hainaut preuve
c'est qu'on a eu les trois federer
particules est sombre il s'est coincé
dans un pot dans une marmite l on n'est
pas là pour débattre sur son histoire
alors va pas juger ok c'est pas ça
convenait pas mais il ya une pension
d'invalidité au quelqu'un sujet l'état
non mais pourquoi y ait deux baguettes
pourquoi il me bat mais je sais pas mais
j'ai envie de savoir déjà la gorge et
après l'effort le réconfort
regardez-la plus chaud en fait
j'aimerais savoir comment s'y retrouver
là-dedans je vais raconter son histoire
ok c'est un mec est sorti de la douche y
avait une fuite d'eau dans la salle
d'avoir du mak la femme elle a mis un
chaudron en dessous la photo au hockey
pour pas que ya un dégât des eaux sur
son sol ça marche ça tu as compris un
truc sur moi s'ils font des
concentrateurs lala à l'eau
à tanger l'avoir à l'usure comme le bac
le mari de cette femme était sous la
douche et un matin donc les news ça
marche incroyable sort de la douche
qu'est-ce qui est là mais non c'est la
vraie histoire ou bas c'est la vraie
histoire du jeu tombé à la fois un art
histoire j'ai menti quand tu cherches le
dessus du puits mais comment faire
[Rires]
l'accent max il fait plein de copains
surfer night je pense qu'il peut y
arriver en fait vous êtes allés où tout
ce qu'on a je veux dire la vérité
et allez juste au dessus de l'arbre et
maxence c'est fou mais poupe et non pas
parce qu'il ya d'autres gens qui doit
venir
ils sont tous dans color c'est bon mais
il faut prendre son temps radieux
[Musique]
il a l'habitude les attend c'est
probablement un homme tronc il n'a pas
sa carte d'invalidité ben oui mcfly on
sait que tu es pas youtuber jeux vidéo
et on pense que tu vas y arriver à qui
on a confiance en toi par contre juste
un truc ne suffit pas d de respirer fort
pour y arriver avant moi la grande
indépendance
oui le truc en métal et n'est pas bien
mis sur le truc il faut le le tape un
peu ça change et a accordé un petit peu
de bricolage ne fait pas demain je pars
en dab au aux amateurs maintenant
attendons ne soit pas ne soient pas des
gars si tu as aimé
moi j'ai nommé non mais mcfly moi j'ai
une mission aujourd'hui il faut que
j'arrive à aller au bout de ce jeu on
m'a envoyé des gens pour m'aider mais là
ce qui se passe et passe à conduire au
niveau regarde aller ça dégage appelle
le suivant ce bleu et libertés ouais tu
t'appelles comment je m'appelle marton
c'est pour ça qu'on aime avec swatch et
martin martin c'est le mec a connu
martin tu as dix secondes pour nous
impressionner
c'est parti allez ça dégage
ma garde à vue j'ai vu ça vous dit rugby
vous au pied bon oeil la révue pied de
chaise
on peut dire il prend son pied donc moi
je dois aller le plus loin possible
l'impossible j'ai rien on compte sur toi
c'est pas pour que ses partis alliés
on est parti c'est notre sauveur sombre
encourager giraille à gérer en direct
son prénom il au passé simple
c'est une chaîne du mot que vous avez
donc ouais ok j'ai regardé longuement
vers la gauche voilà voilà
tu connais pas et gilles va chercher
jamais cassé les membres seraient connus
au monde grâce à lyon pourquoi ils
continuent pas il était très fort est ce
que c'est bien de figues et on avait du
sang romero max écoute moi bien
gj nous a menés jusqu'à ce point ses
roues était une aventure longue
périlleuse aussi compliqué parsemez de
blagues de qe2 karito qui était très
très bien on compte sur toi
vous at on besoin kg était pas
à part vers l'humain gouvernement priait
pas je viens pas du tout va bien les a
vraiment tout va bien on est sur un mois
parce que qu'est-ce qui est en moi j'ai
pas vu ça m'emballe à yann hovine de
carriço faut surtout pas y aller se
passe des choses de fou on financer les
[Musique]
prêts consentis lors si je ne parle plus
faible accès payant ce matin il y avait
plus de chouquettes à la boulangerie
j'ai avancé l'a déjà la fin c'était bien
cela me fait penser qui est justement
moi une fois j'allais boulangerie pas du
tout pour acheter des chouquettes ça te
rassure bâti nanterre et malines médias
on a pu atteindre cet endroit de l'amap
c'est très haut si tu tombes ici à
gauche on recommence d'une élue ne tombe
surtout pas là alors je vais je vais
manipuler et ça va
un kit sa plateau mais c'est pas le
bateau qui s'appelle m
madame toit sert il a fait perdre toute
notre progression tuer leurs espoirs de
cette vidéo qu'il a aucun espoir avec la
barre était ok what u mais vers la
droite pour aller vers la gauche y est
ça oui je récapitule cb derrière la
porte depuis une heure de concert qu'on
va invoquer la triforce m'étais voir
secteur puis c'est la force des yeux
larry pense l avance des meilleurs
laisse filer la vie force et la force
des meilleurs pu forcer la force des
meilleurs
[Musique]
m
mais notre interview l'espoir
[Musique]
ah ah
et
ouais
paris
[Musique]
millas la paix
moi non
[Musique]
le
[Applaudissements]
et
[Musique]
ouais